PERSONAL POLITICAL VENDETTA.
AINSLEY: LET’S BRING IN LARA
TRUMP, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND
DAUGHTER-IN-LAW TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, GOOD MORNING TO YOU,
LARA.
>> GOOD MORNING, GUYS.
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
AINSLEY: GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON.
WHAT DID YOUR FATHER-IN-LAW,
WHAT DID YOUR HUSBAND, WHAT DID
YOU THINK WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION
TO SEEING DONALD TRUMP THERE ON
THE BORDER?
>> WELL I THINK IT WAS
FANTASTIC TO SEE SOMEBODY
ACTUALLY GO DOWN AND TAKE CHARGE
OF THE SITUATION.
I MEAN, I’LL TELL YOU THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP BEING THE FORMER
PRESIDENT SURE GOT A LOT MORE
ACCOMPLISHED IN HIS VISIT TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER THAN THE ACTING
BORDER CZAR, KAMALA HARRIS DID,
WITH HER PHOTO OP TRIP TO A
PLACE 800 MILES AWAY FROM WHERE
THE REAL PROBLEM HAPPENS TO BE
DOWN ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER, SO
I THINK THE BORDER PATROL ARE
HAPPENING THAT THEY FINALLY HAVE
SOMEBODY THEY’RE SUPPORTING THEM
, SOMEBODY BACKING THEM UP.
IT WAS CERTAINLY NICE TO HEAR
SOMEBODY TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM.
YOU KNOW, YOU’LL HEAR THE
DEMOCRATS ALL DAY LONG, JOE
BIDEN, KAMALA HARRIS TRIED TO
TIP TOE AROUND THIS AND NOT TALK
ABOUT IT BECAUSE IT IS A CRISIS.
THEY DON’T WANT TO ADMIT IT AND
THEY DON’T WANT IT TO BE ON
THEIR BACKS QUITE FRANKLY.
THEY’RE HAPPY TO HAVE AN OPEN
BORDER AND THEY RAN ON AN OPEN
BORDER POLICY SO THANK GOODNESS,
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS DOWN
THERE AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER
TAKING CONTROL OF THE SITUATION,
AND WHAT HE SAID YESTERDAY, GUYS
, WAS SO ACCURATE.
IF THEY HAD JUST DONE NOTHING IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN BETTER THAN WHAT
THEY’VE DONE.
DONALD TRUMP HAD IT SETUP SO
WELL.
WE HAD RECORD LOW BORDER
CROSSINGS UNDER HIS TENURE AS
PRESIDENT AND NOW YOU SEE THE
DISASTER THAT HAS ENSUED
IN A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME WITH
THE BIDEN-HARRIS ADMINISTRATION,
SO THANK GOODNESS SOMEBODY IS
PAYING ATTENTION FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
STEVE: WELL AND YOU KNOW,
AMERICA WHEN HE WAS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT, DONALD TRUMP SAID
I’M GOING TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
I’M GOING TO BUILD A WALL AND
MAKE MEXICO PAY FOR IT, COULD
NOT GET CONGRESS TO PASS THE
MONEY, AND SO HE DECLARED A
STATE OF EMERGENCY, AND REDIRECT
ED SOME MONEY FROM THE
PENTAGON THAT WAS THE WAY HE
WAS ABLE TO GET THE MONEY TO
BUILD THE PORTIONS OF THE WALL
THAT GOT BUILT, LARA.
>> YEAH, THAT’S RIGHT.
WELL SOMETIMES, YOU HAVE TO TAKE
MATTERS INTO YOUR OWN HANDS, AND
DO WHAT IS BEST FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AS PRESIDENT.
WE KNEW THAT THE DEMOCRATS WERE
NEVER GOING TO BUY INTO THE IDEA
OF BUILDING A WALL.
THEY DEEMED IT TO BE A TERRIBLE
IDEA.
WE KNOW THAT WALLS WORK, AND YOU
CERTAINLY HAVE SEEN THE RESULTS.
WHEN DONALD TRUMP WAS IN OFFICE,
ALL WE NEED TO DO IS COMPLETE A
VERY SMALL SECTION OF THE WALL.
I HEARD YOU GUYS TALKING ABOUT
IT A FEW MINUTES AGO.
HOW SAD IS IT THAT IT’S
BASICALLY BEEN PAID FOR.
WE HAVE ALL OF THE SUPPLIES
THERE, EVERYTHING IS READY TO GO
, YET THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
REFUSES JUST TO PUT UP THESE
SECTIONS OF WALL.
IT’S ALREADY DONE.
I DON’T KNOW WHY YOU WOULD NOT
WANT TO DO WHAT IS RIGHT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I DON’T KNOW WHY YOU WOULDN’T
WANT TO DO WHAT’S RIGHT FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE MAKING
THIS DANGEROUS JOURNEY.
DEINCENTIVEIZE THEM TO COME HERE
TELL THEM WE’VE GOT A WALL
YOU’RE NOT ALLOWED INTO AMERICA
IT SEEMS TO MAKE SENSE BUT AGAIN
I DON’T EXPECT TO HEAR A WHOLE
LOT OF THAT FROM THE BIDEN-
HARRIS WHITE HOUSE.
BRIAN:  LET’S TALK ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING AND THAT IS DEFUND THE
POLICE AND THEY ARE TRYING
REVERSE AND PUT IN REPUBLICANS.
I DON’T THINK ANYONE LOOKS AT
THIS SERIOUSLY.
I DON’T THINK IT PASSED THE
LAUGH TEST BUT ONE PERSON IS
ALARMED THAT WASN’T BRIEFED ON
THE FACT THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO
DO A JUJITSU WITH IT IS
CONGRESSMAN JAMES CLYBURN.
HE ALWAYS SAID THIS IS ONE OF
THE DUMBEST THINGS HE’S EVER
HEARD AND HERE IS HIS QUOTE WHEN
ASKED WHY HE WAS ENDORSING A
MODERATE CANDIDATE INSTEAD OF
THE BERNIE SANDERS CHIEF OF
STAFF, SINCE SHE WENT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE, SAID THIS , "WHAT I
TRY TO DO IS DEMONSTRATE BY PREC
EPT AND EXAMPLE HOW WE
PROCEED AS A PARTY.
WHEN I SPOKE OUT AGAINST SLOGANE
ERING, LIKE BURN BABY
BURN, IN THE 1960S AND DEFUND
THE POLICE WHICH I THINK IS
CUTTING THE THROATS OF THE PARTY
I KNOW EXACTLY WHERE MY
CONSTITUENTS ARE.
" THEY ARE AGAINST THAT AND I’M
AGAINST THAT.
OF COURSE, IN SOUTH CAROLINA,
THEY DON’T WANT TO DEFUND THE
POLICE, YOU KNOW THAT BEING
FROM NORTH CAROLINA.
>> YEAH, I AGREE WITH
CONGRESSMAN CLYBURN HERE.
HE’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
NOBODY WANTS TO DEFUND THE
POLICE IF THEY ARE BEING
REASONABLE AND RATIONAL HUMAN
BEING.
THE IDEA THAT THIS WAS GOING TO
SOMEHOW HELP ANYBODY IS
ABSOLUTELY INSANE.
WE HAVE SEEN THE RESULTS OF WHAT
DEFUNDING THE POLICE DOES.
IT ACTUALLY HURTS THE MOST THESE
INNER CITY COMMUNITIES THAT ALL
OF THE  BLM RIOTERS WHO HAVE
BEEN CHANTING "DEFUND THE POLICE
" WERE SUPPOSEDLY
TRYING TO HELP.
IT IS HURTING THEIR COMMUNITIES
THE MOST.
WE KNOW THAT CRIME IS
SKYROCKETING, MURDERS ARE UP, I
MEAN IT’S A REALLY SCARY THING
TO SEE HAPPEN IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA, SO YEAH I
GUESS HE DIDN’T GET THE MEMO
GUYS THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY
WERE GOING TO TRY AND FLIP THE
SCRIPT, BUT HE’S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
DEFUND THE POLICE IS A TERRIBLE
IDEA AND YOU SEE THE RESULTS OF
IT NOW, SADLY AND SO MANY OF OUR
BIG CITIES IT’S WHY EVERYBODY IS
LEAVING.
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING NEW YORK IN
DROVES.
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING CALIFORNIA,
ILLINOIS.
IT’S TERRIBLE TO SEE BUT IT IS
BECAUSE PEOPLE DO NOT WANT TO
LIVE IN A LAWLESS SOCIETY PLAIN
AND SIMPLE.
STEVE: AND CRIME IS THROUGH THE
ROOF.
ALL RIGHT, YOU KNOW, I’M SURE
YOU WERE WATCHING EARLIER THIS
WEEK.
WE SHOWED IMAGE OF GWEN BERRY
WHO CAME IN THIRD OVER THE
WEEKEND IN THE HAMMER THROW
AT THE OLYMPIC TRIALS, AND
DURING THE PLAYING OF THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM, SHE TURNED
HER BACK AND SHE SAID SHE HAS
SINCE SAID LOOK, I LOVE MY
COUNTRY.
THERE’S BEEN A LOT OF FALL-OUT
FROM IT AND AS IT TURNS OUT
APPARENTLY AN OLD PHOTO OF HER
HOLDING AN AMERICAN FLAG WENT
VIRAL AND IT APPEARS ON HER OLD
PERSONAL WEBSITE, TOUTING HERMAN
IT ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
THERE SHE IS, QUITE PROUD ABOUT
THE AMERICAN FLAG IN THAT
PICTURE.
AINSLEY: AND LARA, WHEN SHE WAS
ASKED ABOUT IT SHE SAID THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM HAS NEVER
REPRESENTED HER BUT THERE SHE IS
IN AN OLD PHOTO HOLDING UP THE
FLAG.
WHY THE SWITCH, DO YOU THINK?
>> YEAH WELL I DON’T THINK
ANYBODY IS SURPRISED TO SEE THIS
THIS IS WHERE THE INTERNET
ACTUALLY CAN COME BACK AND HAUNT
YOU, FOLKS.
YOU POSTED A PHOTO PROUDLY
HOLDING THE AMERICAN FLAG AND
YET YOU KNOW WE SAW THAT
RIDICULOUS DISPLAY FROM HER
WHENEVER SHE CAME IN THIRD PLACE
THERE.
HOW DISRESPECTFUL THAT WAS TO
THE OTHER WOMEN THAT SHE COMPET
ED WITH.
LOOK, I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT
THIS IS A STUNT.
THIS WAS AN  ATTEMPT, A VERY
SELFISH ATTEMPT AT THAT, BY HER,
TO MAKE A NAME FOR HERSELF, TO
CAUSE SOME WAVES.
I KNOW SHE PROBABLY WANTED AN
ENDORSEMENT FROM SOMEBODY OF
SOME SORT AND SHE THOUGHT THIS
WAS THE WAY TO DO IT.
WELL HOW DISRESPECTFUL TO
AMERICA, HOW DISRESPECTFUL TO
OUR TROOPS.
YOU KNOW WHAT IF SHE WANTS TO
COMPETE UNDER THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA, I THINK SHE OWES AN
APOLOGY TO EVERY AMERICAN.
I THINK SHE OWES AN APOLOGY TO
EVERY SOLDIER THAT HAS DIED
FIGHTING FOR OUR FLAG, TO EVERY
FAMILY THAT HAS LOST SOMEONE
WHOSE DIED FIGHTING FOR OUR FLAG
, SO IT’S NOT THAT EASY TO
JUST TURN AROUND AND SAY WELL I
DON’T HATE AMERICA.
YOU VERY CLEARLY DISRESPECTED
EVERY AMERICAN.
YOU DISRESPECTED THE WOMEN YOU
COMPETED WITH AND YOU DISRESPECT
ED OUR FLAG, SO I
THINK IT’S VERY CLEAR SHE DID IT
FOR A SELFISH REASON AND IT’S
DISGUSTING TO SEE WE DO NOT NEED
TO HAVE ATHLETES LIKE THIS THAT
OUR CHILDREN ARE GOING TO LOOK
UP TO.
WE NEED BETTER REPRESENTATIVES
FOR THE UNITED STATES, GO
COMPETE SOMEWHERE ELSE UNLESS
YOU WANT TO APOLOGIZE.
BRIAN:  SHE DID THE IMPOSSIBLE
AND ESCAPED FROM NORTH KOREA,
GOT THROUGH MONGOLIA, HAD A
ROUGH TIME, SOLD OFF TO SLAVERY,
GOT HERSELF FREE IN SOUTH KOREA
AND CAME OVER TO COLOMBIA FOR A
COLLEGE EDUCATION, LOOKED AROUND
AND CANNOT BELIEVE HOW
UNGRATEFUL AMERICANS ARE FOR THE
COUNTRY THAT THEY HAVE.
WE WANTED TO PUT GWEN BERRY
STORY UP NEXT TO YON ME PARK,
THE NORTH KOREA DEFLECTED FROM
COLOMBIA AND NOW A HUMAN RIGHTS
ACTIVIST AND HERE IS WHAT SHE
SAID.
>> IN NORTH KOREA, PEOPLE WHO
ARE ACTUALLY OPPRESSED DON’T
EVEN KNOW THEY ARE OPPRESSED.
THE FACT THAT SHE’S COMPLAINING
OPPRESSION AND SYSTEMIC RACISM,
THAT SHE DOES NOT UNDERSTAND
THAT SHE’S SO PRIVILEGED.
IT’S AN  AMAZING COUNTRY.
I WAS A SLAVE.
I WAS IN CHINA IN 2007 AS A
CHILD AT 13 YEARS OLD.
THE PEOPLE ACTUALLY GO INTO
SLAVERY UNDER THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY IN NORTH KOREA,
THERE IS ACTUALLY INJUSTICE AND
THE FACT THAT SHE’S COMPLAINING
ABOUT THIS COUNTRY, SHE DOESN’T
REALLY UNDERSTAND HISTORY.
STEVE: AND LARA, YOU’D MENTIONED
A SPONSOR TURNS OUT WE
DISCOVERED YESTERDAY THAT GWEN
BERRY IS SPONSORED BY A DE
FUND THE POLICE ORGANIZATION
THAT APPARENTLY IS GETTING THEIR
MONEY FROM PUMA SHOES.
>> YEAH, THERE YOU GO.
WELL THAT YOUNG WOMAN YOU JUST
HEARD FROM THERE, FROM NORTH
KOREA, IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
GO TO ANY COUNTRY IN THE WORLD
OTHER THAN AMERICA.
YOU WILL NOT HAVE IT AS GOOD.
WE ARE THE GREATEST COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD, AND I REALLY HOPE
THAT PEOPLE START REALIZING THAT
AND STOP FALLING FOR THE
NONSENSE.
WE SHOULD ALL STAND UP PROUDLY,
PUT OUR HANDS OVER OUR HEARTS,
AND RESPECT OUR AMERICAN FLAG.
I SURE HOPE WE SEE IT AT THIS
YEARS OLYMPICS.
STEVE: AND I’M SURE WE’LL SEE IT
A LOT THIS WEEKEND WITH THE 4TH
OF JULY.